[Musique]
explication des sacs
au programme 65 m
des caldera c'est à voir c'est
magnifique ce fruit
il ya pas mal de
la descente vers saint philippe
plaisir à ses amis l'ouverture de la
saison longue et ride soit plus dense et
plus une place de tests plutôt que
pour aboutissement tout la même
[Musique]
je les chinois n'ont deux heures a quand
même une heure de course enfin le soleil
se lève le jour au le jour le jour se
lève le soleil est encore loin voilà
beaucoup depuis ce matin on est vraiment
dans la terre des hommes ce qu'on
appelle la terre des hommes
c'est ce qu'on va voir tout de suite 3
de la caldeira traille sont en train de
passer
on est sur un site qui a été entièrement
aménagé avec une spécificité qui est la
renaturation paysagère site de pique
nique vous pourrez revenir quand vous
serez lors de la course
ce qu'on appelle des espaces de
renaturation qui reprennent en fait la
végétation éricoïde donc la végétation
du massif du volcan et on recrée le
paysage originel puisque ici c'était une
forêt de cryptomerias avaient été
plantés objecter que ce sera plus tard
demain là faut continuer non il y en a
qui arrivent là pascal annoncé pas lui a
déjà la bleue dire toute la journée la
wii ça réchauffe mes mains c'est moi le
ballon
[Musique]
bien protégé
ça va être une belle journée je pense
que le meilleur est à 25 ans
ok on va voir un mètre cinquante d'eux
dans 25 ans moi c'est un bon dieu là
[Musique]
la mouvance prier à la demande un petit
peu les ménages y toute façon voire rien
du tout il ya de l'eau beaucoup et là on
va remonter le long de la cage des rats
la deuxième caldera si je me trompe pas
et ça va être une crête magnifique
j'espère qu'on va voir quelque chose en
tout cas bien mouillé
waze des coureurs les conditions sont
difficiles comme vous pouvez constater
le volcan sens mérite dans le
département fait un projet de mise en
valeur touristique de la route du volcan
est un site qui accueille plus de six
cent mille personnes par an sites
majeurs du domaine naturel départemental
et donc c'est un projet de développement
touristique au travers d'une route
d'interprétation au travers de
l'aménagement des grands belvédère qui
raconte finalement l'histoire géologique
au travers de d'information de ces
caldera et ça peut être également
l'objet d'une découverte via une
application multimédia que le
département a à développer qu'ils
appellent la fournaise
mais avant tout le temps comme ça il
faudra y offre d'or se sent complètement
il faut être courageux a aidé treiber
prochaine étape ma longue alors c'est
beau oui impeccable gel a laissé
beaucoup de jus ce qui s'était passé a
obtenu un sourire sur tout le monde
surtout quand je vois des beaux arts
comme ça alors là là là là
bon c'est pas que la défense non
récémment sérieux ça va mieux carrément
bien nous voilà au pas de bellecombe
juste avant de redescendre de l'autre
côté vers saint philippe
enfin la pluie s'est arrêtée hélas comme
on peut le voir même avec le brouillard
et ben c'est juste magnifique
ça me désole et là
[Musique]
même le dernier a toujours devant celui
qui ne fait rien
[Musique]
oui
et toujours un petit oiseau qui vous
suit dans les sentiers c'est
impressionnant comme la végétation a
totalement changé à un mètre près
quelques pas et bim
on est dans une forêt humide avec des
palmistes les arbustes le sentier qui se
recouvre toute cette biodiversité
vous avez des questions on a les
réponses
pas trop dur non ok cool là on est sur
le chemin de lac albert a trahi et là on
voit bien combat en sort de la forêt
primaire qu'on voit sur la droite où il
ya le sentier botanique et sur la gauche
mais on voit une forêt plus de
production du volcan jusque jusqu'au
littoral on retrouve différents types de
végétation la visitation des branches au
sommet des montagnes
la viola pourrait de bois de couleur des
eaux et ensuite ici la forêt de bois de
couleurs débat si la réunion est classée
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
c'est notamment grâce à ça à ses séries
de végétation qu'on peut retrouver d'un
seul tenant du littoral jusqu'au sommet
jusqu'au volcan
[Musique]
fort de ses terres de travail spécial
caldera et mare longue on finit comme on
a commencé sous la pluie
une belle aventure
à bientôt nice est entier